ce qui s'est passé ce soir là c'est que
j'ai été heurté par un bateau qui veut
qu'il venait sur mon tribord que je n'ai
pas vu jamais eu des feux de position
j'affirme que je n'ai pas vu ces feux de
position face à ces feux de route plus
tôt j'ai vu chez lui en particulier ce
qui m'a assez des plus que j'avais pris
la fuite
or je suis resté immobilisé cloué sur
place durant trois quarts d'heure alors
que l'autre bateau a continué son chemin
et ce moment ni mobilisation n'a pas pu
lui échapper trois quarts d'heure pour
relever tous le mouillage qui était à
l'eau 30 mètres de chaîne a3 et pour
apaiser les plus terrifiés qui étaient
dans le bateau vu la violence du choc
on parle de témoignages des témoignages
que d'un bateau nous étions six dans le
mien tout le monde est à disposition
je pense que l'examen des deux
embarcations avec les dégâts qu'il ya
chez l'un et chez l'autre reconstituera
pas pas mal le choc et la vitesse de
chacun le lendemain j'ai essayé de
joindre la gendarmerie du marin qui est
lié aux affaires maritimes et en fait
aucune déposition des possibles dans la
mesure où les yoles
et d occuper à temps plein et donc qu'on
m'a dit de reprendre contact lundi
ah bon ça je vais pas réparé